you could make a feature-length film
with all these bloopers the free guy
cast and crew seemed to have a ton of
fun on set which led to these hilarious
bloopers let's see how many we can find
hiding around free city that is
unexpectedly odd it's like losing my
virginity but in my mouth who knew
getting coffee could be so exciting
reynolds improvised a bunch of different
lines during the scene where he gets his
daily coffee reynolds exaggerated facial
expressions along with his ridiculous
one-liners were enough for the actress
working with him and some of the crew
members to break into laughter
hottest beverage ever going straight to
the hospital
only someone as amazingly odd as ryan
reynolds could come up with the line oh
it's like heaven wept in my mouth we
don't blame them for laughing
wow who put a flavor grenade in my mouth
pull the pin a bright light on set
accidentally turning on during a take
was all taika waititi and jokiri needed
to start goofing around as soon as the
light turned on watiti immediately
stopped delivering his line and gave a
perplexed look in the direction of the
light kiri joked they're here as a
reference to an alien invasion and why
tt promptly started to be beamed up
taika ytt was a delight to work with
according to the cast and crew actress
jody comer said she would come to set on
her off days just to watch him one great
example of why tt's riffing abilities
came when he improvised a bunch of
different lines about why sequels are
better including a puntacular steven
seagal joke who's the best martial
artist in the whole wide world
steven sequoia director sean levy
praised by tt's comedic abilities
taika ytt takes an already funny script
and
is ripping on a level that is freaking
sublime waititi was able to make
something as mundane as peeling tape up
into a funny moment when the director
called for him to move over a little bit
waititi started to remove his marker
tape but had some trouble his inability
to get the tape up paired with his
impression of a child complaining had
everyone laughing it started sticking
chaining tatum plays a video game
character in the film and the person
controlling him in the real world is a
streamer who goes by the name
revengementbuttons this name gave tatum
quite a difficult time as he kept
getting tongue-tied when trying to
deliver his line we don't know how long
it took but he was eventually able to
get out a clean take
i hate this word i hate this name
channing tatum had trouble with another
line during the same scene as his
revengement buttons blunder this line
was it's crime o'clock baby
simple enough but tatum accidentally
added a w to the word baby resulting in
a hilarious blooper
it's crime o'clock baby it's fun
during a setup for a take the director
yelled to joe curie to back up and why
tt wasted no time piling on yelling at
joe to back it up
when they did the take again it was the
same result with the director asking joe
to back up and waititi enthusiastically
seconding that command
lil rel howery improvised a ridiculous
backstory for a random character when
his character buddy was explaining all
the security guards he knows he made up
a story about a guy named frank crazy
legs whims and explained all the weird
things his legs do including a weird
shuffle and how they look like a zero
this of course resulted in laughter it's
very confusing
[Laughter]
one very simple yet funny blooper
involved a crew member that accidentally
wandered into the shot they realized
their mistake and immediately ran out of
frame as everyone seemed bewildered by
the seemingly brazen act
taika waititi's childlike humor was on
full display during this outtake a crew
member asked waititi to stand in frame
for quote one second of course waititi
took this literally popping into frame
for a mere second and popping back out
good morning goldie
ryan reynolds didn't hold back when
talking to his goldfish their
interactions in the movie may seem
friendly but this outtake shows reynolds
wasn't messing around behind the scenes
poor goldie
don't be a
goldie
getting tongue tied seems to be a
running theme for the actors in this
film lil rel was trying to say the word
mermaids but it somehow got jumbled into
man murdered howary was as perplexed by
the blooper as we are and kept trying to
figure out just exactly what he had said
man mates i don't know merman
yet another tongue-tied moment comes
again from howery in this instance
howery was playing with actor aaron
reed's pex who played dude in the movie
he was trying to say he's spectacular
but instead said he's spectacular
when blue shirt guy puts on the glasses
for the first time after having his
memory erased he is taken aback by what
he sees reynolds exaggerated reaction
was too much even for him as he broke
character and started to reset to do
another take turns out they didn't need
another take though as they kept his
over-the-top reaction in the film
during a scene when taika waititi is
arguing with joe kiri's character he
mentions arnold schwarzenegger i don't
care if he's arnold frick and schwatz
invader in one of the outtakes waititi
attempts to do an impression of arnold
but quickly abandons the idea turns out
impersonating arnold schwarzenegger is a
weak point for the talented ytti
[Music]
sometimes it's not the actors themselves
that cause a blooper wardrobe snafus can
be just as big an issue in one scene
taika waititi's long jacket got caught
on his chair causing him to be pulled
back and ruined the tape
little roll howery couldn't keep his
balance during this one take he was
supposed to run up to the edge of the
set and look off but accidentally went
too far and lost his balance so he had
to bail out at the end and jump off
tycho was always goofing around on set
and no one was safe from his antics not
even the camera itself during one take
waititi grabbed the camera got
intimately close and proceeded to stick
out his tongue because why not
that is the thing that people want
reynolds always has the right jokes at
the right times to crack up his co-stars
while filming a scene that sets up the
final act of the movie reynolds quipped
i think we just figured out the third
act it sent jody comer into laughter and
we can't blame her
one outtake showed jodie comer asking
ryan reynolds can you make me laugh
before ryan could even respond comer
burst out laughing which tends to happen
when you're next to one of the funniest
men in hollywood reynolds wasn't too
confident in his abilities however as he
responded with probably
stay humble ryan
waititi seemed to be able to find
moments for jokes and gags and even the
simplest of situations in this instance
taika put his finger in the clapboard
right before it clapped down getting his
finger caught we wonder how they got
anything done with him on set
in between takes jodie comer decided to
do a snap in point gesture which caught
herself off guard she started laughing
at herself as she wondered why she made
the gesture in the first place
that's my man waititi proved that he
does have some self-awareness when it
comes to his ability to get a clean take
when filming one of his scenes he
confidently said
before they did another take and then
shortly after followed it up with before
i get it right at least he gave everyone
on set a fair warning
it's no secret taika waititi had an
absolute blast on set and his dance
moves are just more proof of this one
moment in particular had waititi
spotting the camera on the ground and
dancing towards it without hesitation we
love that man's energy that's the thing
about antoine you never know which one
you're gonna get
you can always expect some great
bloopers when the hilarious ryan
reynolds and taika waititi are involved
free guy was a fun film and the actors
and crew all seemed to enjoy creating
the movie what was your favorite blooper